almost every approach to teaching
relativity Begins the same
you get a set of pseudo-mystical
sounding statements time and space are
relative
the universe has a speed limit
there is no ether reality is a
four-dimensional entity exhibiting
curvature
and so on
then you are told certain empirical
experiments prove the math and the math
in turn proves the philosophy
but does a mathematical formalism ever
necessarily necessitate a single
interpretation
certainly this isn't the case with
quantum mechanics which sports a rich
diversity of viable and competing
philosophies
of course this might lead you to
question are there other interpretations
of Relativity out there
and if so should we be teaching them
this is dialect with
the real reason you don't understand
relativity
[Music]
last year we successfully debunked a
major myth of general relativity which
went along the lines of time dilation
causes gravity
at the time this idea appeared to us to
be so ludicrously in contradiction with
the basic tenets of Relativity that we
assumed it had to be a product solely of
the YouTube sphere
but after publishing our video we
discovered to our surprise that the
misconception extended far beyond
YouTube appearing in textbooks and even
quoted by renowned physicists
this of course got us wondering how
could such brilliant people get their
own Theory so incredibly wrong
well the answer is because relativity
very much like quantum mechanics is
extremely confusing and it's doubtful
anyone truly understands it of course
with quantum mechanics this fact being
openly acknowledged has led to a rich
and intriguing field of Diversified
interpretations
but in relativity everyone carries on
just as if they were all teaching one in
the same interpretation the one they
call Einstein's
the problem is few people are acquainted
with Einstein's actual work and don't
know that Einstein never really had a
solid interpretation of relativity
most people teaching relativity are
unaware for instance that Einstein
himself didn't believe in the
conventional solution to the twin
paradox or in absolute acceleration that
he didn't believe in black holes that he
didn't believe in Cross terms of the
line element that he didn't believe in
the geometrization of gravity or most
shockingly that he did Believe In The
Ether or at least that he reversed his
stance on it in 1920 when before an
audience at the University of Leiden he
declared that general relativity
necessitates space b endowed with
certain physical qualities and since the
special theory of relativity does not
compel us to deny ether that therefore
there exists an ether
indeed a number of major shifts in
Einstein's interpretation of Relativity
can be traced throughout his lifetime
and he died never really having made up
his mind about what the Theory actually
meant
in his wake he left an immense
philosophical vacuum which modern
physicists are still trying to fill in
with their own ideas today
the result is an extraordinary and
inordinate confusion which you can see
clearly on display in the wide number of
personal interpretations that
professionals give to their explanations
such differing interpretations can be
found in any number of YouTube videos
but today we're going to pick on one in
particular
Sabina hasenfelder's why you
misunderstand relativity
now we enjoy sabina's Channel and we
were in fact greatly appreciative of
this video on the whole since it
corroborated our own video from a few
months earlier about how you're
accelerating up at the surface of the
Earth
but on the flip side this video also
brings several contradictory statements
into immediate proximity to one another
and in doing so demonstrates just why
relativity is so badly in need of better
interpretations
no this isn't an attack personally on
Sabina in any way and she has plenty of
great content but we do feel that her
arguments in this video are
representative of the confusion of the
greater physics Community as a whole
now the video gets off to a strong start
with Sabina emphasizing the formalism of
Relativity over its philosophy and
explaining that our confusion about
relativity stems from the simple fact
that we're treating time dilation too
literally that is taking it to be
something physically real when it's
rather just an artifact of how we choose
to do measurements and draw up
coordinates
the time that passes between two events
is not the time on the coordinate axis
that's just a label it's convention it
has no physical meaning this is what
people often call time dilation I'd call
this pseudo-time dilation because it's a
meaningless comparison why would you
care about the coordinate time it's just
a label it has no physical meaning for
Bob all of this is great and it seems
very in keeping with Einstein's original
1905 special relativity paper wherein
you won't find too many Grand statements
about the nature of space and time
itself but rather just a simple
demonstration of how adopting light as a
basis for our spatial temporal
measurements conveniently reproduces the
already well known at the time Lorenz
transformations
but a few minutes later into the video
while Sabina is discussing the twin
paradox she gives us this statement the
way he travels this is the real-time
dilation it comes from the acceleration
this is the real-time dilation the
real-time dilation the real-time
deletion like what
first she was telling us we were
confused about relativity because we
were treating time dilation too
literally and now she's saying time
dilation is something literal and to
understand the theory you need to accept
a fact that only minutes earlier was
stated to be the source of your
confusion
again like what
let's slow down for a second
more precisely Sabine is saying here
that time dilation is only real for the
special case of acceleration
but as she implies in the beginning it's
the idea of any sort of time dilation
being real that confuses people indeed
by saying that time dilation is only
real for acceleration she thinks she's
resolving the source of our confusion
but she's not she's merely transferring
it from the case of velocity to the case
of acceleration
secondly she neglects to mention that
observers who aren't accelerating will
not perceive the same manner of time
dilation as those who are
in a uniform gravitational field for
instance observers who are stationary
within the field I.E those who are
accelerating will see clocks at
different positions ticked at different
rates
but an observer Free Falling in that
field you'll see those same clocks all
ticking at the same rates no matter what
their location
thus any Observer not sharing in the
acceleration won't be able to agree on
the time dilation of the clocks
so by no means can we claim accelerated
time dilation to be any more or less
real than velocity-based time dilation
they both are coordinate Observer
dependent phenomena
now Sabina does point out that a more
meaningful comparison of time
ought to happen when observers are
rejoined at the same place to compare
clocks
which is why she brings up the twin
paradox
but she gets something very wrong when
she says that the real-time dilation
comes from acceleration the asymmetry of
the Paradox certainly comes from
acceleration
but to Alice Bob's velocity or
kinematical time dilation is very real
and the cause of his slowed aging
and to Bob Alice's kinematical time
dilation is likewise also very real
but now in his case there's an
additional accelerative time contraction
which he has to add atop the kinematical
dilation
thus it's actually the kinematical and
accelerative time dilations slash
contractions taken together that
describe the real proper time
if you leave either of them out the math
fails
now if you want a quick and dirty
rundown of the math we recommend you
watch this short video by minute physics
it's simple and easy to follow and it
will give you the necessary insights
about why kinematic and accelerative
time dilations and contractions need to
be taken together
indeed saying only accelerative time
dilation is real while kinematical time
dilation isn't is not only incorrect
it's also not an explanation you'll come
across in any textbooks or historical
works so Sabinas being a little
disingenuous here and claiming she's
teaching Einstein's interpretation as
she's actually just teaching her own
additionally earlier in the video she
actually rejects Einstein's preferred
explanation to the twin paradox which is
the gravity-based one
of course as we discussed earlier it's
likely she's entirely unaware that
Einstein even had a preferred solution
to the twin paradox
but this just demonstrates our point
that nobody knows exactly what
interpretation of Relativity they are
teaching and generally they just fill in
the gaps in their understanding with
their own ideas
here sabina's own ideas are quite in
confusion as it's clear she can't decide
what level of ontological reality to
ascribe to the phenomenon of time
dilation
indeed physicists being unable to make
up their minds about what the meaning of
time dilation actually is is probably
the biggest source of confusion in
relativity and why you get such
backwards ideas like time dilation
causes gravity
is time dilation something real
something that should modify our idea of
true immutably flowing time or is it
just an artifact of how we've chosen to
formulate our Theory and draw up
coordinates
this is where the formalism of
Relativity doesn't provide any clear
answers and consequently where the
personal interpretations begin to flow
if we want to treat time dilation as
something real then sense different
observers don't perceive the same manner
of time dilation as one another we
seemingly have to accept a solipsistic
world view where different observers can
construct different narratives of their
existence
on the other hand if we reject the
reality of time dilation we're left
scratching our heads over just how it
comes about that certain clocks can be
empirically observed to run slower or
faster than others
but what if it were the case that there
were other interpretations of Relativity
out there
interpretations that reproduced the
formalism but which steered clear of the
heavy-handed space and time altering
pseudomysticism of Relativity altogether
interpretations in which there was no
time dilation or spatial contraction to
begin with no relativity of simultaneity
or funky stretching or shrinking of
measuring instruments
would you feel you deserve to know what
these interpretations are or do you
think physicists should go on teaching
relativity as it currently stands
a theory with a perfectly functioning
formalism
but with its philosophy caught in a
limbo so uncertain that even Einstein
couldn't make up his mind about it
well we can't make that decision for you
but we can say that if we want to move
towards a more consistent interpretation
of relativity we need to re-examine one
Assumption of Relativity in particular
the Assumption of absolute acceleration
indeed it's this assumption which Sabina
uses to justify her interpretation that
only accelerative time dilation is real
but it's an assumption Einstein could
never bring himself to accept
indeed if you want to know Einstein's
actual thoughts on the topic we suggest
you read his 1913 paper entitled on the
relativity problem because you might be
surprised by what you find there
we also suggest you watch sabina's video
more carefully around the 17 minute Mark
and ask yourself why she says that the
spring which is brought in there has to
come from outer space
indeed a more thorough examination of
the problematic notion of absolute
acceleration will help guide us towards
a better interpretation of relativity
we're saving a full treatment of that
topic for another video but for the
moment we can with certainty say that
this statement Sabina gives us at the
end of her video is not correct
and rather than clarifying things for
her viewers it merely demonstrates her
own confusion about the theory
which of course brings us to the real
reason you don't understand relativity
you don't understand it because the
people teaching it to you don't
understand it
at the end of the day this isn't a huge
deal as quantum mechanics demonstrates
that you can teach a formalism just fine
without the accompanying Clarity of
philosophical principles
however the first step to overcoming a
problem is admitting that you have one
and relativity unlike quantum physics
suffers from a serious case of denial
but if you like us are after the truth
then you know no harm can come of asking
critical questions and exploring new
ideas
so hold on to your socks because our
channel is about to move into Uncharted
Territory
this has been dialect stay tuned